this is what the future of genetic
engineering looks like
with Advanced DNA editing techniques
vaccines for deadly infectious diseases
with no side effects are developed in a
matter of weeks
from any plant or animal can be combined
to create new hybrid organisms resilient
to climate change this technique can
even restore extinct species
doctors can detect every known genetic
disorder early on and pair of mutations
quickly giving children happy and
healthy lives
our environmental clock is taking today
scientists are blazing a trail to this
very future tinkering with James is
actually an ethical thing to do I want
to know what breakthroughs are being
made Technologies like Crystal are
incredibly powerful what we're doing
here is really the beginning of a true
Revolution that will Forge the future
too that is incredible the rise of
genetic engineering
[Music]
thank you
my name is khandwani Peri I'm a genetic
researcher you could say it's in my
blood from an early age of about eight
or nine or so I had just a Natural
Curiosity for the natural world cancer
runs in my family in fact I lost my aunt
to breast cancer and that piqued my
interest in in genetics I'm fascinated
by how the genes we inherit to shape our
biological Destiny including our health
I believe the key to treatments and
cures for diseases like these lies in
explicit efforts to engineer human genes
but can be fixed not only what's broken
but also enhance our genetic codes and
improve on Mother Nature
someday will humans direct their own
evolution
and should we
I'm starting my journey in Washington DC
to visit a family who's grappling with
the difficulties caused by genetic
disease
hello hi Annabelle
can you shake hands Annabelle hi
oh my gosh how are you oh I think she's
shy
four-year-old Annabelle Frost has a
heart-wrenching genetic disorder can you
tell me a little bit about Annabelle
when edible was born it was such a
wonderful moment but we were in this
happy fog and didn't notice the
nystagmus that the eye movement
we didn't notice the jerky muscle
movements we didn't notice any of that
but the doctors realized that something
was wrong they diagnosed Annabelle with
alternating hemiplegia of childhood or
ahc
this extremely rare disorder causes
debilitating spells of paralysis delayed
development and life-threatening
seizures
so you'd have days of paralysis where
her full one side of her body she'd drag
it along behind her as she crawled
[Music]
you know once a day she will have these
choking episodes where I need to pick
her up and hit her on the back to make
sure that she could breathe
Annabelle's condition is a result of a
problem in her DNA the twisting double
helix of DNA is made up of four
different base pairs or nucleotides
the unique sequence of these base pairs
are instructions for the body to make
proteins
the base pairs are like musical notes in
a score that tell a musician how to play
a song
when all the different sections of the
DNA are played the result is a
biological Symphony
but like a musical note played out of
key that compromises the entire
performance
there is an error in one of Annabelle's
genes
the mutation in the atp-1a3 gene is
disrupting her nerve cells leading to
her severe condition
ahc is fundamentally intertwined in her
genetic code there is no restorative
treatment or cure
the medicines that they have are kind of
more about masking symptoms in a very
unspecific untargeted way and we wanted
to try to figure out if there was a way
to address the cause and not the
symptoms without targeted treatment
Annabelle could die any day
[Music]
timeline on this for us would regretted
taking Clark in the back of our minds
all the time the frosts are desperate
for any kind of help
sickle cell anemia to Huntington's
disease millions of people suffer from
thousands of genetic disorders much like
Annabelle's unless scientists can
address these genetic errors children
like Annabelle will suffer agonizing
pain and some will die young I want to
know can genetic engineering help
families like this in the future
oh that's so nice
the double helix structure of DNA was
first revealed in 1953 by Rosalind
Franklin Francis Crick and James Watson
and within a few decades scientists
discovered how to alter the DNA of
living organisms
but Gina didn't really took off around
2013 when scientists harnessed the
molecular mechanism found in certain
bacteria this remarkable mechanism is
called crispr cast 9 or crispr for short
crispr cas9 contains an enzyme that
serves as the bacteria's defense
mechanism against viruses when viruses
infect the bacteria the crispr Machinery
targets the specific section of DNA then
the enzyme responds like a pair of
scissors and literally cuts the virus
genetic code apart scientists are not
harnessing this natural mechanism to
Target and precisely edit the DNA of
numerous organisms
foreign
to find out how I'm heading to a biotech
lab in Brooklyn New York
I'm on my way to gen space which is the
world's first Community biology lab
tuck is the director of Science
Education at gen space we are
yeah so he told me if I'm a computer
programmer and I want to learn more
about biology I can essentially come
down here and take a class in easier
facility that's it
Beth is going to show me how to use
crispr in the lab to edit a bacteria's
genes in new and novel ways I brought
these kids could you explain a little
bit how this kit works yeah sure got a
pipette this is our measuring device
got a rack where we'll put our some of
our plastic tubes some plates Petri
dishes and then our E coli
E coli is a type of bacteria that lives
in the intestines of humans and animals
though some strains can be deadly most
are harmless
[Music]
gloved up let's do this all right so
we've got our E coli here these are
called dh5 Alpha which is a type of
species that isn't harmful to people
with normal immune systems that's good
to know so our first thing that we need
to do is actually get these bacteria out
of this jar
is you just kind of scoop it in there
yep swirl it around bring a little bit
up the way that this experiment works is
we're going to spend a day to prepare
the bacteria
next we insert a crisper construct that
will alter their DNA so we're going to
add in the crisper machinery and then
the crisper Machinery targets and edits
a specific Gene in the E coli so that it
can adapt to a lethal dose of
antibiotics
normally bacteria can't grow in the
presence of this antibiotic the drug
kills the bacteria we need to get these
bacteria onto this plate so they can
grow you're just going to gently drag it
across the surface of the plate that's
it yeah that's it
over the course of several days Beth
grows the gene edited bacteria in a
Petri dish laced with the E coli killing
antibiotic but despite this toxic
Onslaught the genetically altered E coli
continued to grow
I see plenty of growth
the whole point of this is to show that
change and organism's DNA
DNA really precise way in a way that
wasn't feasible before the kind of
positive outcomes can we expect from
using crispr you can use it to design I
knew on the spot testing for infectious
diseases you can use it to cut out HIV
from human cells there's so many more
uses that we haven't even imagined yet
that to me is why this stuff is so
exciting harnessing the natural ability
of crispr and transforming it into a
technological tool has the potential to
address all sorts of problems
in the future Advanced Gene editing
techniques are reworking microbes to
create healthier lives bacteria are
engineered into many pharmaceutical
factories these microorganisms generate
an inexpensive abundant supply of
medicines for diseases like malaria
rabies and Coronavirus
and specially modified yeast converts
organic waste into green biofuels this
Innovative energy source is not only
renewable but it also packs more of a
punch than regular fossil fuels
formulated by Charles Darwin natural
selection is the driving force of
evolution
while many individuals perish the
species best adapted to their
environment survive and reproduce
passing along their advantageous genetic
traits to their offspring
traits like heights eye color strength
and even personality are contained in
genes over Generations the process of
natural selection perpetually fine-tunes
the species at the genetic level
helping individuals to continually adapt
to changes in their environment
humans learn to direct this evolutionary
process through artificial selection
through the intentional selection of
mates humans facilitated the breeding of
animal Offspring with desired
characteristics
arguably the first known example of
artificial selection happened more than
15 000 years ago when humans
domesticated the wolf reading what we
now know today as the dog
in agriculture artificial selection has
improved and even created new fruits and
vegetables
through selective breeding for certain
traits the simple wild mustard plant was
transformed into cauliflower cabbage and
even broccoli but even artificial
selection takes at least a few
generations to work
capitalizing on the natural crispr
process Gene editing in the lab can
compress Evolution down to a matter of
months
using crispr to manually engineer DNA is
the next step in accelerated Evolution
and with this remarkable tool scientists
can even improve our food supply
this matters because over 10 percent of
the world suffers from hunger and
malnourishment I'm in Raleigh North
Carolina where pioneering food
scientists Dr rodolf barangu is using
gene editing to boost food production
and feed the planet we're going to be
able to breed crops that are more
efficient that are more resistant to
disease the biggest impact whisper may
have short term maybe the next decade or
so will be to revolutionize a food
supply chain in fact rodolf had a hand
in the discovery of the natural crispr
mechanism in bacteria and his use of
crisp Reza technology in milk is leading
to remarkable Innovations in dairy
products so what we're looking at here
is milk that is the process of
fermenting okay so this is in the
earlier stage of things very real estate
so we add the bacteria to start the
fermentation process and then use the
lactose insulated five milk into cheese
and yogurt in most Dairy facilities
regular bacteria and yeast kick-start
the fermentation in process but before
starting rodolf added a Twist he used
crispr technology to enhance the
bacteria used in the fermentation of
milk
we used it to build resistance in
bacteria that make cheese and yogurt to
have better fermentations and better
manufacturing of their products by
vaccinating the bacteria his Dairy
cultures almost always succeed which
improves the process of making yogurt
and cheese
processes like these also make them
healthier crispr has been a life changer
and then also has opened tremendous
Avenues to provide a healthier and more
sustainable food supply for Humanity but
the true revolutionary potential of
crispr technology is just now starting
to be realized
other people caught on to using these
molecular machines to actually cut DNA
to do genome editing not just in
bacteria but in other organisms
by understanding what crispr is and how
it works scientists were able to develop
technologies that enable us to now
change the world
by 2050 the world population is expected
to soar to 10 billion people food
production will need to increase 70
percent to catch up
to feed our growing population with the
same amount of Farmland the mass
production of food must be hyper
efficient
at NC State's plants and microbial
biology lab gordolf's collie Mary Beth
Dallas is facing this daunting Prospect
I manage this lab and I also do research
on cassava
also known as the yucca plant cassava is
the primary food staple of nearly 1
billion people cassava plant is very
close to my heart
this root vegetable is kind of like a
potato and is widely grown across Africa
and the Americas they can actually
harvest the tubers and make flour and
they can make breads out of that they
can also eat the greens it's really a
nice plant yeah and me being a native
Zambian that's where I was born I I grew
up eating cassava as well as cassava
Leaf so yeah especially I know all about
it so it has a special place in my heart
I spoke to it but there's a problem
a Melody called cassava Mosaic disease
is ravaging this critical food source in
Africa alone it's destroyed cassava
crops leading to numerous famines
you can see here the devastation
of the plants it gets really thin leaves
and a mosaic pattern occurs when the
leaves get destroyed like this they
cannot photosynthesize properly and the
tubers that are under the ground cannot
get the right nutrients and they get all
shriveled and then you can't use the
tubers for the food
we want to combat and try to find a way
to stop the devastation of these crops
to wage this war Mary's lab must take an
experimental approach
[Music]
it's called a gene gun crispr altered
DNA is injected into the cassava plant
we bombard the stems with the crispr
construct
and what happens is the leaves grow up
in Principle as the leaves and tubers
grow from the stem the plants will
become more resistant to the crippling
Mosaic disease when did we see a
possible usage in African countries that
are afflicted we're still trying to hone
in that technique so hopefully we'll get
it soon
imagine Gene editing could help end
world hunger this is also applicable
Beyond crops to things like trees
forests maybe the biggest farms that we
have
but as the human population grows so do
our agricultural needs this leads to
deforestation which is one of the
primary causes of climate change
contributing to the record high
temperatures we see today
to reverse this scary Trend one solution
is to plant more trees to absorb
greenhouse gases like carbon dioxide
Rudolph is collaborating with tree
biologist Dr Jack Wang to grow more
trees and fast
what do we have here so these are
transgenic trees Jack's lab has created
over 10 000 types of genetically
modified trees the goal is to optimize
traits for different Industries like
Timber or paper to reduce their
environmental footprint with the liver
crisper into these cells once crispr is
altered the tree DNA the embryos then
grow enhanced roots and shoots so this
has been engineered precisely voice
specific genetic change using crispr
this helps Jack to select for specific
traits more quickly and efficiently than
traditional plant breeding so there's a
little bit of seedling there's now a
tiny little crisper editor forestry
spacing this is at this stage just
before it goes into the greenhouse
that's why it's now ready to be grown
for five to six months fantastic it's so
cool
Jack's next step is taking these
seedlings over to the greenhouse where
they'll be fully grown and studied I'm
careful 50-20 years to take to breed a
tree and a natural population
in the greenhouse setting we can analyze
and produce new genetically and
filtration as little as five to six
months that is incredible six million
months
here they're quickly growing poplar
trees which is the most effective
species at absorbing carbon dioxide from
the air it can capture a very large
amount of carbon from the atmosphere and
we have to start solving the problem
right here right now we can not afford
to wait for another 20 or 30 years this
technique for breeding trees is giving
reforestation efforts a major jump start
our environmental clock is taking
everyone to create a better healthier
environment for future Generations it's
something that has to be done now what
we're doing here is really the beginning
of a true Revolution the next Green
Revolution coming to a forest near you
yes
I think it's going to revolutionize our
world and solve the grand challenges
that we have on the planet a new crispr
Field Green Revolution Will Forge a path
to a more bountiful world
[Music]
in the future Gene edited plants are
addressing world hunger and climate
change
enhanced food crops grow in harsh
conditions even in water parched deserts
thanks to these disease-resistant plants
famines across the world are a thing of
the Past new fast-growing forests
collectively take in the excess carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere cooling the
climate and restoring balance to the
world's ecosystem
foreign
is both a faster and more precise method
for artificial selection
while it works in microbes and plants
how feasible is Gene editing in more
biologically complex organisms like
animals
I'm in Davis California to meet
geneticist Alison van enenam she's a
Pioneer in this field
and I'm getting acquainted with her work
[Music]
no
scientists tend to be problem solvers
and want to try and address problems
using the best method they can
and my lab is trying to breed better
cattle
there are about 1 billion cattle on
Earth that's a lot of animals to manage
but Allison is making cattle Farms safer
by eliminating one particular trait I
see some horns up here okay dairy cows
have been bred to be very optimal for
dairy production and as it happens dairy
cows grow horns and these horns are a
problem because they injure other cattle
and ranchers you could imagine if if
this was a particularly aggressive
bullet he could hurt hurt his pen mates
instead of manually sawing off these
horns Alison is breeding a dairy cow
that doesn't grow them in the first
place
working with a type of cattle that has
no horns she had their hornless Gene
inserted into horned Dairy Bowl cells
these cells were cloned to make the
hornless animal
these hornless cows are descendants of a
gene edited hornless bull that is a
proof of concept animals they are kind
of a prototype of how you could use
genome editing this genetic technique
produces offspring with a desired trait
much more quickly than the Decades of
breeding normally required in
traditional animal husbandry that's
really what editing does for us is it
enables us to bring in one useful
characteristic that we want in this case
not growing horns and not all to the
rest of the genetics this technique
shows that Gene editing tools can be
used to introduce desirable traits from
one animal into another
foreign
of trying to remove the horns are there
any other Expressions that we would want
to get rid of or add so what else might
we do one of the targets that's a really
obvious one for plant and animal
breeders is disease resistance and so
globally it's estimated we lose about 20
percent of all animal production to
disease
that's hundreds of millions of cattle
needlessly lost every year to me
genetics is the best approach to deal
with disease because if they don't get
sick they don't need to be treated with
antibiotics they're more productive
farmers happy cattle are happy consumers
are happy so it's kind of a triple win
for sustainability but there's an even
more fundamental trait that Allison is
trying to select for in the beef cattle
industry we would actually prefer males
that's because male beef cattle produce
quantitatively more meat per pound of
feed than females so Allison is also
using gene editing to breed cattle who
only produce male offspring to achieve
this she inserts a special gene into cow
embryos in the lab this makes selecting
the male sex possible this could save
more animals from being slaughtered and
techniques like these could be used to
insert disease resistance potentially
reducing the need for antibiotics
in fact a gene edited embryo was
implanted into this cow just three
months ago and there's princess
so in a few short moments we're about to
see an ultrasound of a cow here
veterinarian Brett McNabb is going to
perform an ultrasound on the princess to
see if the gene edited embryo has taken
hold
[Music]
we're just going to make sure that the
pregnancy is still healthy and viable
from what we can tell so an ultrasound
on a cow is not quite the same as an
ultrasound
but the principles are the same but our
approach is a little bit different
Allison's checkup may depend on the
whims of this mama cow to get the
ultrasound scanner up heard
well you know
[Music]
you're doing that next time you know I'm
learning quite a bit just observing
she's pregnant that's good news it
appears the embryo implant has
successfully taken hold
so an ultrasound you know we use sound
waves and so anything that's more dense
is going to bounce the sound way back to
my probe and then you can start to see
floating around in there are those
bright white structures those are all
parts of the calf
oh yeah okay
based on certain structures we can sex
the uh the calf and it looked like a
male
for Allison's Endeavor to breed male
only beef cattle this is a significant
Milestone while these techniques are
still experimental and haven't yet been
approved by the FDA Allison believes
that consuming products from Gene edited
cattle poses no threat to human health
artificially selecting for the male sex
could make cattle production more Humane
and more efficient there are some pretty
compelling benefits that outweigh the
the risks
seeing the genetic engineering of
livestock up close and personal is
absolutely mind-blowing
[Music]
in the future engineering the genes of
farm animals speeds up their evolution
as useful domestic species a new variety
of cow Gene edited to dramatically
reduce the emission of the climate
damaging gas methane is vastly reducing
global warming
organs from genetically modified pigs
are safely implanted into humans without
fear of rejection from the immune system
no one dies from a lack of an organ
donor anymore
foreign
s have selectively bred plants and
animals refining the traits for
thousands of years
we've even created hybrids by mating
creatures from two different species
for example a donkey and a horse make a
mule
but in the lab mixing up genetics can
result in anything and well everything
jellyfish DNA spliced into a bunny
results in a fluorescent bunny when
spider DNA is edited into goats your
milk can be spun into spider silk
hybrids like these are often
bioengineered for research purposes
but one scientist is using crispr's
cross-breeding abilities to do something
truly ambitious he's bringing back the
genes of extinct species I'm in
Cambridge Massachusetts to meet Dr
George Church a legend in the field of
genetics one of The Originators of Gene
engineering he's been working in Russian
Siberia to find the remains of woolly
mammoths with the aim of resurrecting
their DNA to fight climate change
there's unfortunately lots of melting
ice in Siberia and millions of mammoths
that are frozen that are becoming
exposed we had access to six really
excellently frozen specimens that never
thawed in 40 000 years when you were
grabbing the samples from the wooly
mammoth anatomically where
we're dissecting big chunks of Mammoth
legs with a drill bit and we're kind of
suited up because there's meat flying
all over the place
due to over hunting and environmental
changes woolly mammoths began going
extinct around 10 000 years ago but
George is extracting their DNA from the
cold preserved remains in Siberia and
mapping their genome as we read The
genome into the computer and then we
write it into modern Asian elephant
cells modern Asian elephants and woolly
mammoths share a common ancestor but are
two distinct species
George is using Advanced crispr
Techniques to resurrect multiple cold
resistant genes from The Woolly Mammoth
that grow extra hair and produce more
fat he then plans to integrate these
genetic traits into the eggs of Asian
elephants
we can make dozens of edits to the
genome and then clone them into a baby
elephants but why
it turns out cold resistant elephants
could also help mitigate global warming
in The Frigid Tundra of Siberia grass is
more effective at keeping the arctic
cold than the current Forest environment
which retains heat those billions of
square kilometers are at risk of warming
and it's the only herbivore that can
knock down the trees is the elephant
oddly the herbivores can change it back
to Grasslands which is more
photosynthetic
sizable population of cold resistant
elephants would help maintain this
region as grasslands through grazing
and a more photosynthetic Arctic would
absorb more carbon dioxide so it's part
of what will hopefully be a big
International effort to convert the
Arctic at least partially back to the
form that was more conducive to fighting
climate change is it outside of the
realm of possibility to say bring back
an extinct feature like a woolly mammoth
once we get that good at it we may
switch the cold resistant elephants into
fully genetically identical mammals who
knew resurrecting woolly mammoth DNA can
help restore icy conditions across the
Arctic
in the future genes from most creatures
can be safely inserted into other
species to create revolutionary hybrids
engineered jellyfish with genes from
plastic eating microbes now clean up the
oceans by organically breaking down
non-decomposing trash some scientists
have even extracted DNA from dinosaur
remains and are on the brink of
resurrecting these extinct species
the hope is by bringing a single
dinosaur back to life new technologies
will be developed to help other species
on the brink of Extinction
speaking with George Church firsthand is
both humbling and inspiring as if
resurrecting the DNA of the woolly
mammoth wasn't enough he also helped
start the three billion dollar Human
Genome Project this Landmark study
identified every base pair of DNA and
mapped the entire human genome
primary purpose was to conquer diseases
it was and remains a really big deal
we are here to celebrate the completion
of the first survey of the entire Human
Genome this road map of the intricate
genetic codes across the human body
empowers doctors to better diagnose and
treat disease
we've worked really hard on bringing on
the cost of reading genomes which I
think is the thing that most people
could benefit from thanks to advances in
DNA sequencing technology the cost of
reading entire genomes has plummeted all
it would take is a small Tipping Point
event shifted over so that everybody's
using this and in the case of genetics
that would be reading everybody's genome
and giving them information that was
actionable
by actionable he means letting
individuals know what kinds of diseases
they're genetically susceptible to
this empowers people to be proactive in
avoiding or managing imminent diseases I
think we're on a trajectory where
everybody in the world are going to get
sequenced within a few years the Human
Genome Project continues to have a big
impact in treating all kinds of human
diseases
to find out how I'm at the historic Cold
Spring Harbor laboratory in Long Island
New York to meet with Dr Bruce Stillman
there's been a Revolution coming from
the Human Genome Project and a lot of
cancer research is linked to that we now
have a very deep understanding of that
genetics and what that can do is to link
new Therapeutics to individual patients
genetics I have an interest in oncology
I'd lost an ants to to breast cancer and
I think that took me down this journey
towards finding a solution one of our
scientists used a very interesting
genetic technique of genetic selection
and now we're gearing up
to use that information to improve
cancer therapy
founded in 1890 this lab is home to
eight Nobel Prize winners so this was
the first Lab at Cold Spring Harbor and
still used this is a cancer laboratory
so still used for cancer research
scientists here are using gene editing
techniques including crispr to develop
new ways to fight cancer
these advances are leading to treatments
tailored to work with an individual's
unique genetics so for instance if you
have a mutation in a particular Gene
that causes lung cancer there is a
therapeutic that is targeted to that
lung cancer
but in the shadow of its long history of
using genetics to improve human life
Cold Spring Harbor Labs do have an
unfortunate and dark past
[Music]
what happened in the 19 teens and the
1920s was that scientists began to
believe that a lot of
traits were inherited by individual
genes when in fact they weren't
this led to an air of what's called
eugenics that is the selective breeding
of humans
Cold Spring Harbor Labs even opened the
Eugenics Records Office to gather
biological information on the American
population
[Music]
at the time people certain traits that
some believe to be desirable were deemed
fit to reproduce while minorities and
those with disabilities were blocked
from marrying and were even sterilized
that Eugenics movement got way off track
from science
scientists pushed back against this
Eugenics movement and by the 1930s it
was effectively shut down in the United
States
despite this skeleton in the closet it's
important to know our history so as not
to repeat it from what I see at Cold
Spring Harbor Labs today I think there's
plenty of room to be optimistic
when real science is conducted true
progress can be made and the best place
to start is with affected children
we have worked on a disease called
spinal muscular atrophy which is a
mutation that children inherit the child
will eventually die but the laboratory
developed a drug which actually prevents
these children from dying and actually
gives them a fairly high quality of life
all this makes me think of young
Annabelle Frost and had debilitating
genetic disorder
this kind of research fills me with hope
in fact genetic engineering can even
remedy genetic disorders like sickle
cell anemia caused by mutation this
disease deforms blood cells into
hook-like shapes which can stick
together and cause life-threatening
blood clots
it's now being used to change genes and
sickle cell anemia
where you then transplant back into
those patients cells in the blood system
that will essentially reverse the sickle
cell disease
and those types of Trials are occurring
now with crispr recently scientists Gene
edited a patient's own stem cells that
produce bone marrow they then
re-injected these altered cells back
into her body
amazingly this therapy cured the
patient's sickle cell disease for the
first time in history Technologies like
crispr are incredibly powerful and can
change the world
they also have the potential for
changing Humanity as itself
but there are limitations
crispr technology is not perfect
sometimes it makes mistakes in the
genetic reworking that could be
catastrophic
this means crispr's implementation
directly into humans remains a risky
Prospect but one Visionary scientist is
aiming to give Gene editing techniques
and even higher level of precision
Dr David Liu of the broad Institute of
Harvard and MIT is working on tools and
techniques that may One Day lead to the
safe Gene editing of humans
he's developing a new Gene editing tool
called Prime editing can you tell me a
little bit about your work in that
regard so the machines that nature
provides us like crispr cast 9 often
don't do what we want them to do the
results of breaking that double helix
most frequently disrupts things to cause
the deletion or insertion of small
numbers of DNA letters at the cut site
both crispr and Prime editing
Technologies work by cutting DNA but in
some sensitive situations crispr
technology can be too blunt of a tool
that's because it breaks both strands of
the double helix in rare instances this
can disrupt the gene in unintended ways
but Prime editing is more like a pair of
tweezers it breaks only one strand of
the double helix allowing scientists to
very precisely change a single base pair
this is like changing one note in a
musical score for most diseases with a
genetic component it's believed that in
order to to treat the disease you need
to precisely change that mutated Gene
back to the normal DNA sequence
this Ultra precise technique means David
can replace an individual mutation on a
single step of DNA and not an entire
section of the ladder
so you can make those kinds of changes
using prime editors the kinds of changes
that we believe could directly correct
genetic disease-causing mutations
in the lab David has successfully
corrected mutations for genetic diseases
including Tay Sachs and cystic fibrosis
and he thinks this Prime technology will
soon be ready to help people with
genetic disorders like Annabelle
how far off would you say is a potential
human application we should have some of
the first drugs ready by perhaps as
early as within the next five or ten
years it's an incredibly exciting time
if you had asked me five or ten years
ago I would have said it still is in the
realm of Science Fiction yeah that's
that's wonderful
this experimental technique will become
science fact giving affected individuals
the prospect of a better life
now reworking the genetic codes of
people remains controversial in 2018 a
researcher stunned the World by using
crisprit to Gene edit HIV resistance
into the embryos of a pair of twins
called germline editing this technique
on humans was considered premature and
was widely condemned in the scientific
Community
the first Gene editing in humans was a
profound misuse of science with profound
implications in society in general the
involved parties were punished for
disregarding safety regulations
fortunately or unfortunately the
Pandora's box of genetic engineering has
been thrown wide open
in many ways this is one of the costs of
doing science
the technology itself is agnostics
neither good nor bad the real question
is what do people do with that
technology and how careful and or
mindful are they to the potential
unintended consequences that we have
with the depth of control over Evolution
that Gene editing enables in breeding
plants animals and eventually humans
we're entering uncharted waters as a
species it's difficult to draw a hard
line between where progress should stop
and where our morality or our ethics
should come in some might argue that
some lines have to be crossed to to make
progress
and there has been much progress
especially in agriculture today more
than 90 percent of corn and soybeans are
genetically modified or GMO these crops
require less pesticide land and water
scientists are also using gene editing
to develop crops that are more
nutritious and even drought resistant
though meaning the public remains
skeptical the vast majority of
scientists believe GMO foods are safe
tinkering with Jane's four benefit and
for good purpose is actually an ethical
thing to do
and as for humans many believe the
benefits of Gene editing outweigh the
risks there are 10 000 monogenic
diseases affecting hundreds of millions
of children across the world precise
medicine would help and then we start
building on them
in the right hand I genetic engineering
will Usher in a much better future for
people and our planet
some think it will even shift human
evolution into overdrive in 30 years we
may be unrecognizable I don't think
that's going to be Our intention but
when you take these big leaps and get
comfortable with them people get
addicted
I'm hopeful that Gene editing technology
will ultimately help people like my aunt
and Annabelle
for those reasons and many more I
believe the rise of genetic engineering
can't come fast enough
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]